Wally, congratulations! That was amazing!
Great job Wally
Kid Flash! Let 'em know!
That's how it's done!
We just deposited Plunder in Iron Heights
Yes, you did!
His real name is Jared Morillo, turns out he's wanted for a string of robberies from here to Star City.
Wally! What was that! You're supposed to be shadowing me
wait, you're mad at me?
observe and learn, that's it!
whoa, whoa Barry wise up
Wally just saved your life!
I'm sorry Wally, but if you can't learn to follow orders, this deal between us is over.
Okay, who's ready for awwww man
Wallace, BA, you're supposed to be dressed for the museum opening.
HR, we're speedsters, we have time.
nobody likes a braggart
yeah, but we were talking about something important before you showed up
You clean up well
I like the way you dress
Guys, this is a very very big deal for all of us, 'cmon!
Don't be late to the party!
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie swearing at some
footage for the next episode of the flash
so let's break it down.
Also remind everyone what's going on with
the schedule.
There is a new round of the flash ring giveaway
going on right now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video.
Make sure you click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss anything during the break
just at first glance this is a really simple
scene about Barry training Wally West Wally
not listening just like Jesse quick Jesse
totally did not listen to Barry.
When he tried to train her during the mere
master fight.
So what's happening here is that Wally just
super eager and Barry is so weighted down
with all the crap he knows is going to happen
because, of savitar it it's causing him to
be a bit of an ass hole.
So you need is like a Jay Garrick type person
to come in and just tell them all to chill
the Frak down but HR comes in and says the
museums getting ready to open remember he's
trying to turn star labs into a museum which
sound like a precursor to the flash Museum.
So we know that's going on, but the title
of the episode is borrowing problems from
the future, so that is more of a hat tip to
the other big thing in this is the kind of
casually drop which is plunder another Jeff
John's Wally West era villain which we heard
about.
When Barry traveled to the future, so there
literally borrowing a character problem from
the future this probably some other stuff
happening to inform the title to but that's
the only thing we can guess based on this
clip so the thing about him is that he actually
makes me wonder if they're going to do the
Wonderland arc from the Jeff John's run which
is a Wally West story so way back in the early
2000 a long time before Jeff John's ever brought
Barry Allen back in the first flash rebirth.
I know gets confusing when we talk about rebirth.
Because they have the new DC rebirth going
on right now with its own flash rebirth.
So the original flash rebirth is the first
time Barry Allen came back.
But before then for almost like eight or nine
years.
Jeff John's Road a lot of Wally West stories
and plunder debuted as a rogue during an arc
called Wonderland.
So Wally West gets trapped in the mere universe
where he doesn't have his powers and everything's
different is like a darker version of our
reality.
So it's kind of like a version of earth two
from the flash TV show season to where zoom
had taken control and all the Meadows were
evil.
So while Wally West is trapped, powerless
in this mere universe being arrested by the
police.
The rogues send plunder back to the regular
universe to cause a bunch how they can make
a big distraction while they take care of
Wally West.
So what they might do because we haven't done
mere world yet is they might use a multi-verse
story or they might choose not to do that
at all like the spring plunder on and he'll
be a distraction for something much bigger
because plunder is like a regular bounty hunter.
He's dangerous but he usually works with someone
else or somebody else using him as a distraction,
so that could be the other flash rogues or
it could be savitar because with exception
to alternate earth stories like gorilla Grodd
or any of the special small arcs are going
to do savitar is the big villain of one of
the smaller villains is going to be working
for another big villain that big villain is
probably going to be savitar one of the other
things that made me think of the Jeff John's
Wonderland arc is because there's this image
on the cover of the first issue of flash getting
carted off to prison we've never heard of
the flash were taking you to jail and he doesn't
have his powers.
So he gets stuck in prison he just has to
rot there for little while till he can get
out.
When Barry ran back to save his mother at
the end of season one we saw a flash forward
of him in prison that could be how he ends
up in prison, but the thing I don't think
they'll do is mere world they might just use
an alternate earth or they might find some
way for Barry to lose his powers briefly,
or somehow just end up in prison.
It just that usually the stand-in for mere
world is like another Earth's like were going
to go to earth.
19 eventually we been to earth three they
might just use another earth instead of doing
straight up mere world from the comics but
I know a lot of you are asking about the prophecy
that savitar gave them like somebody's going
to betray them some was gonna suffer a fate
worse than death.
Someone will fall, so I'm in a do a separate
video about that but I do not think that Wally
is going to betray the team I think it be
super disingenuous for Wally to go through
this entire arc about getting his powers back
like almost betraying the team to become one
of savitar's followers they save them for
him to then just turn around later and do
the exact same thing, so we can talk about
a little more in the future but just expect
of the trail from someone that you would not
think to betray the team using that's what
they do each new season is that character
surprises you like Caitlin sweetest person
ever gets her killer Frost dark almost turns
on the team in a later season.
Cisco almost turns on the team when he finds
out that he might get his brother back then
he comes back from the edge of darkness, so
if someone else on team flash is going to
betray them just expected to be a surprise
somebody that you wouldn't think would normally
betray them.
If you guys want I will do a flash Wonderland
bonus video for like that entire comic book
story and they also revealed no big thing
gypsy from the comics is coming on the show
now.
Her name is Cyndie Reynolds.
So that's probably what the caller when she
comes on the show but her powers are basically
like allusion casting.
She can cause you to see things but she could
like camouflage herself in any environment
and someone is standing next to her.
So that's probably how they're going to use
her powers, but during the new 52.
More recently she showed up during a five
arc in the actor who plays Cisco revealed
that she was coming on the show so she might
have something to do with like a small arcs
for Cisco's character in the back half didn't
say exactly when she's coming on, but it's
gonna be somewhere during the middle of the
run in the back half when we come back so
that just one character I know a lot of you
guys have asked me for video on the accelerated
man, he's the flash from earth.
19 they're going to go to earth.
19.
It'll be a gorilla Grodd crossover story.
So the be all kinds of new stuff happening
that we haven't even learned about in the
back half of the season that I'll talk more
about when they start to reveal stuff but
just reminder the flash is coming back January
24 I'll be doing flash ring giveaway's and
bonus videos every week so no worries is gonna
be a lot of fun so hopefully guys are on break
if you're not caught up on all the DC shows
I would recommend you do that during the break.
I have videos for pretty much everything and
what's happening later tonight is I'll post
my Spider-Man Q&A video so if you haven't
seen the Spider-Man trailer is a post it,
check those out and leave some comments.
If you want me to include in that Q&A we just
wait for that to post you can click here for
my Spider-Man trailer videos and you can click
here to learn all about savitar on the flash
thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!